بالغالبيه ام اتفاق سؤال يطرح ويطرح نفسه
طبعا بقوه عشيه انعقاد البرلمان العراقي
لاقرار الموازنه العامه وسط انباء متضاربه
حول الازمه بين اربيل وبغداد اخر التطورات
تشير الى حذف ثلاث فقرات خلافيه في تلك
الموازنه مع احتمال حسم باقي النقاط
الخلافيه في الساعات القليله المقبله بين
الاكراد من جهه وبغداد من جهه اخرى في هذا
السياق ثمت معلومات حتى الساعه تقول
بالغاء الفقره التي تفرض قطع بغداد
التمويل عن الاقليم خلال 15 يوما في حال
حدث خلاف بين الطرفين حول عائدات النفط
مصادر سياسيه متابعه للقضيه كشفت هنا
لمواقع اخباريه عراقيه عن ضغط يمارسه نور
المالكي زعيم دوله القانون لتحديد الجلسه
حتى من دون الاتفاق مع الاكراد ضغط دفع
مشاه
الموازنه اذا تمت غدا الخميس نعم بالتاكيد
الحزب الديمقراطي سيشارك في هذه الجلسه لا
سيما انه لدينا في هيئه او في هيئه
الرئاسه يعني نائب ثاني وهو من ساهم في
اعداد جدول الاعمال الذي نزلت فيه
الموازنه وبموافقه الحزب الديمقراطي
والاحزاب الاخرى المشاركه في الحكومه نعم
الموازنه حدث مهم وقانون مهم وشعر العراقي
ينتظر الموازنه بفارغ الصبر تقريبا يعني
وصلنا الى نتائج
ملموسه من قبل الطرفين واعتقد ستمضي يوم
الخميس الموازنه وسيكون هناك توافق ان لم
يكن
بتسعين بالمئه ربما سيكون 85% لان بالتالي
لا تستطيع ان ترضي جميع الاطراف السياسيه
ربما 85% من اعضاء مجلس النواب يصوتون على
قانون الموازنه
انسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات